all right so here's a drill to learn the
Makia Tosh mechanics
is not machiatosh this is machiatosh
mechanics what is different is the
timing and that is a lot okay so in this
drill we're going to use the Vulcan as a
training vector and the tsuba
as a minimal protection for this guy for
UK and for us
and intention of
reference point okay as my show
has to go into his Center
it's not going just here
so this is our training Factor
I'm at my angle
I bring the weapon up
this hand
do not open
this hand you can open
don't don't do this extra
thing
he hits my weapon
[Music]
this hand opened that that amount of
Mobility you want in your body find it
in this hand
not in this hand
boom
and my goal
is to not move his sword over
I'm gonna go around his sword
and down
[Music]
different
okay let's get in that ballpark try
at the end of Marcus you have a ski
so my feet have to end up apart
if you reverse that
your feet should start under your hips
so when you do the drill
no
you're going to have a little ski
you want a big ski
boom
shh
so Peter are under your hips
second point
don't have the weapon traveling down
as you're going under
what happens is you get a little hit
only this much joke
so
incorrect
around
you see bound
top
around
no
[Music]
on
okay try it again
the joke
is not going to finish
tip up
nor tip down
it's gonna finish
parallel to the ground
the wrong
wrong parallel
[Music]
second thing
as you come down
you hit
you're going to get his Center
right about here
that is what you check
you don't check his hands
so you have to keep pushing
on his Center you see that
so the Joe will finish
about
six inches to a foot off the ground
that didn't do it
push boom down
parallel about six inches off the ground
okay try
it all right to push his Center down
eventually I'm going to end up on top of
the weapon on top of the weapon on top
of the way not on the side not parallel
foreign
and here's the ski
so here
I didn't ever get on top
here's top
here I'm on the side of the weapon
weight's not on top
on top
okay
okay try